merhaba Bu dersimizde must should ve
have to kullanımını tüm detaylarıyla
öğreneceğiz bu kelimeler başların
eklendikleri fiilin sonuna meli malı
veya zorunda olmak anlamı katıyorlar
must should ve have to kullanımını şu
ana kadar öğrendiğimiz zamanlarda ve
olumlu olumsuz soru cümlesi gibi tüm
cümle türlerinde göstereceğim arada
yardımcı oyuncu olarak da have got to ve
need to kelimelerine değineceğim
ülkemizde İngilizce derslerinde genelde
yabancı kaynaklı kitaplar okutulduğu
için must ve have to konusu öğretilirken
zorunluluğun nereden geldiği anlatılmaya
çalışılıyor okutulan kitap tamamen
İngilizce olduğu için ve derslerde
Türkçe konuşmak da muhtemelen yasak
olduğu için kimse çıkıp da must
Türkçedeki melim mala anlamına gelir He
to ise zorunda Olmaktır diyemiyor
öğrenciler de kitapta anlatılanların
ışığında zorunluluğun nereden geldiğini
yorumlamaya çalışırken telef oluyor Aha
yandan geldi aha alttan geldi şimdi
içten geldi dıştan gelip içe gitti biz
Türkçede sonu melal biten ifadeleri ve
zorunda olmak yapısını nerede ve ne
şekilde kullanıyorsak İngilizcede de
aynı şekilde kullanıyoruz mesela saate
baktınız geç olmuş ve sizin eve gitmeniz
gerekiyor Bu durumda ne dersiniz Eve
gitmeliyim diyebilirsiniz evde yapılacak
acil bir iş varsa eve gitmek zorundayım
da diyebilirsiniz Dolayısıyla bu
kelimelerin Türkçe anlamlarını öğrenmek
kullanım yerlerini ayırt etmek için
yetiyor da artıyor
bile ilk olarak must ve Shut
kelimeleriyle başlayalım bu kelimeler
başlarına eklendiği fiilin sonuna meli
malı anlamı katıyor sadece sertlik
derecesi açısından aralarında fark var
kaba bir benzetme yapmak gerekirse masın
sertlik derecesini 7 şun sertlik
derecesini 3 gibi
düşünebilirsiniz şimdi geniş zamanda
olumlu cümlede bu sözcüklerle nasıl
cümle kurduğumu bakalım 19 videomda Ken
kullanımını anlatmıştım Ken sözcüğü de
bunlar gibi bir model ve kullanım
şekilleri tamamen aynı özne ı ya da ş ı
fiil artı
nesne o zaman hemen örnek cümleler
kuralım You should buy a new car yeni
bir araba satın almalısın sertlik
derecesi 3 olunca ben bunun bir
zorunluluk değil tavsiye olduğunu
anlıyorum arabası halen iş görür durumda
Ama yenisini alsa fena olmaz hani You
must buy a new car Türkçeye aynı şekilde
çevriliyor Fakat bu arkadaşın arabası
artık beni bırak diyor olmalı ki
karşısındaki kişi must kullanmış
ödevini düzenli olarak
yapmalısın kullandığı için bana bir
arkadaş tavsiyesi gibi
geldi regular bahse girelim bunu
öğretmeni söylüyor Çünkü must
kullanmış soruların hepsini
cevaplamalı bence Bu sınavda 4 yanlış
bir doğruyu götürmüyor olmalı ki birisi
böyle bir tavsiyede bulunuyor
Bu sınavda İsa Geçer not olabilmek için
tüm sorulara cevap verilmesi gerektiğini
anlıyorum şut kullanımında olduğu gibi
must kullanarak da tavsiyede
bulunabiliriz ama bu kozumuzu hemen
harcamamak için must ile öyle her zaman
tavsiyede bulunmuyoruz şunu mutlaka
yapman lazım demek istediğimizde
kullanıyoruz bu pastayı tatman lazım Çok
lezzetli ve sözcüklerin bu ıman farklı
olarak tahminde bulunurken
kullanılabilme özelliği de var Önce şu
dile yapılan örneklere bakalım this
motorbike do 200 km Per Hour bu
motosiklet saatte 200 km
yapabilir the doctor should be Here any
minute Doktor her an burada olabilir bu
kullanımda şum can kelimesi gibi ebilmek
anlamı kattığına dikkat edin Tabii Ken
yetenek ş ise olasılık temalı bir
ebilmek bildiriyor
must ile yaptığımız tahminlerde ise
olasılıktan ziyade Akıl yürütme söz
konusu o dahi falan
olmalı sen
olmalısın geniş zaman olumsuz cümle
yapısında da must ve should
kelimelerinin kullanım yerlerinde bir
değişiklik olmuyor cümleyi olumsuz
yapmak için bu kelimelerden sonra not
sözcüğünü getiriyoruz bunu da genelde
kısaltarak
yazıp
okuyoruz sana bunu
söylememeliyim Çünkü doğru olan
bu bu odada sigara
içmelisiniz Çünkü böyle bir yasak var
geniş zaman soru cümlesinde de Yardımcı
fiil gibi davranan bu kelimeleri
cümlenin başına
yazıyoruz Stay Go gitmeli miyim yoksa
kalmalı mıyım
[Müzik]
must today bugün ayrılmalı mı must ile
soru cümlesi yapılsa da çok fazla tercih
edilmediğini söylemde fayda var
inanmazsanız
bakın olumsuz soru yapmak için de
cümleye şunla başlayabilirsiniz mazla
başlayabilirsiniz demiyorum Çünkü soru
cümlesinde bile pek tercih edilmeyen
must olumsuz soru da hiç tercih
edilmiyor okulda olman gerekmiyor mu Tab
bu cümle okulda olmamalı mısın diye
çevirmek çok garip olacağından bu
şekilde
çeviriyoruz ş ve sözcüklerini w soru
kelimeleriyle harmanlayarak da
kullanabilirsiniz wh sorularını her
zaman olduğu gibi soru cümlesinin en
başına yerleştiriyoruz Where Go nereye
gitmeliyiz kimi
görmeliyiz O şimdi ne
yapmalı must ve sözcüklerini Tıpkı
Türkçede olduğu gibi gelecek zamanda
kullanmıyoruz gelelim ceğim gibi bir şey
İngilizcede de
söylenmiyor geçmiş zamanda ise
kullanılabiliyor ancak nasıl
kullanıldıklarını başka bir derste
anlatacağım şimdi have to kullanımına
bakalım have to cümleye zorunda olmak
anlamı katıyor özneye ve zamana göre has
to had to şeklinde
kullanılabiliyor geniş zaman olumlu
cümlede şu şekilde kullanıyoruz özne
Have has to fiil
nesne yani gördüğünüz gibi have to söz
konusu olduğunda mustn't ve shouldn't
kullanımından farklı olarak geniş zaman
kuralları geçerli oluyor beraber
kullanacağımız öznenin tekil veya çoğul
olmasına göre have fiili s takısı alarak
Has şeklinde kullanılabiliyor örnekler
yapalım I have to Finish reps bu
raporları bitirmek zorundayım have to
cch that Flight o uçağı yakalamak
zorundalar
Has ameliyat olmak
zorunda bu son örnekte özne tekil olduğu
için have fiili s takısı aldı ve Has
oldu Daha sonra da sanki İngilizcede
başka kelime yokmuş gibi yine have
kelimesi bu sefer olmak geçirmek fiili
olarak karşımıza çıktı ve has to modan
sonra geldiği için de yalın halde
kullanıldı ya işte neler oldu neler
şimdi geniş zaman olumsuz cümleye
bakalım ve yukarıdaki cümlelerimizi
olumsuz yapalım geniş zamanın yardımcı
fiilleri olan don ve does sözcükleri
devreye
giriyor bu raporları bitirmek
ol zorund
değ Sen hemen dersi bir dah izliyorsun
Çünkü cümle olumsuz olduu için F takısı
gelmiyor ve Fi fabri ayarlarına geri
dönüp olar
kurken yine geniş zaman kuralları
geçerli oluyor ve cümleye do ve does ile
[Müzik]
başlıyoruz soru cümlesinde fiile s
takısı gelmediği için hepsini şeklinde
kullandım Had bir cümleye baar geniş
zamanda olumsuz soru cümleleri yapalım
kelimeleri de geniş zamanda soru sormak
mümkün bu raporları neden bitirmek
zorundasın Neyi yakalamak zorundalar
Ne zaman ameliyat olmak
zorunda söleri zamı
kullanımı anlatabilirim Çünkü to ile
geçmiş zaman cümleleri yaparken 29
derste öğrendiğimiz simple past tense
yani di geçmiş zaman kuralları geçerli
oluyor olumlu cümlede fiilin halini
kullandığımız için fiilinin Hali olan
had sözcüğünü
kullanıyoruz arada değişen şeyleri
görebilmeniz için yine aynı örnek
cümlelerimiz üzerinden
gidelim raporları bitirmek zorundaydım
yakalamak
zorundaydılar had operation ameliyat
olmak
zorundaydı bu cümleleri olumsuza
çevirirken de dili geçmiş zamanın
yardımcı fiili olan didn't sözcüğünü
kullanıyoruz have to Finish Report have
to Catch that Flight have to
operation olumsuz cümlede fiilin birin
halini kullandığımız için Bu cümlelerde
had to demedik soru cümlesi kuralım
Şimdi de you have to finish reps
cch
flation olumsuz soru
yapalım
Finish w kelimeleriyle soru
Catch yapısını gelecek zamanda da
kullanabiliyoruz Ama gelecek zamanda
cümle çok uzayacağı için genellikle will
kullanmayı tercih ediyoruz olumlu
cümleye bakalım I will have to Quit
istifa etmek zorunda kalacağım She will
have to buy Another Computer başka bir
bilgisayar almak zorunda kalacak we will
have to Find an alternative Source of
Energy alternatif bir enerji kaynağı
bulmak zorunda
kalacağız yine Will I have to kullanarak
nasıl olumsuz soru olumsuz soru ve wh
sorusu yapacağımızı uzun uza diye
anlatmıyorum Çünkü aynı kurallar geçerli
Bunun yerine Need fiilinin model
görevinde kullanımından kısaca
bahsedeceğim Need ihtiyaç duymak
gerekmek anlamında bir fiil bakalım
needle neler yapabileceğiz Yukarıdaki
örnekler üzerinden geniş zaman cümleleri
kuralım i need to Quit istifa etmem
gerekiyor Bu cümleden kimsenin onu
istifa etmeye zorlamadı ama koşulların
bunu gerektirdiğini anlıyorum birileri
onu zorlamış olsaydı be supposed to
yapısını kullanırdı ki onu da ilerleyen
derslerimde anlatacağım
başka bir bilgisayar alması gerekiyor
zorunda değil ama alsa hiç fena olmaz
hani alternatif bir enerji kaynağı
bulmamız gerekiyor Bu cümleden de
anladığımız Yani şimdilik Petrol yetiyor
ama y yıl sonrasını
bilemeyiz olumsuz cümle kurarken Need
fiilini iki farklı şekilde
kullanabiliyoruz ilki yine tı kullanımı
gibi
diğeri is kullanımında olduğu gibi
kullanımı Tab Bu ayrıcalığın sadece Need
fiiline ait olduğunu hatırlatır başka
fiiller de bu şekilde
ile ilgili olacak have to yapısını bazen
have got to has got to şeklinde
görebilir ve duyabilirsiniz bu nedir
demeyin ikisi de aynı şey yine şu bizim
meşhur İngiliz Amerikan kullanımı
farkından ötürü ortaya çıkan bir durum
ama her ne hikmetse Amerikalıların daha
çok kullandığını görüyorum Hatta o kadar
sık kullanıyorlar ki günlük konuşmada
have fiilini de atarak sadece Got to
kısmını kullanabiliyorlar şuna kulak
verin
mesela Şair burada gitmek zorunda
olduğunu söylüyor Evet
Bu konuyla ilgili olarak tüm
Söyleyeceklerim Bunlar şimdi bu derste
öğrendiklerimizin kullanıldığı film
alıntılarım gelecek ardından da
çeviriyle öğren kitabımdan konuyla
ilgili alıştırmalar çözeceğiz kitabı
satın almak veya bu dersin yazılı
şeklini PDF dosyası olarak indirmek için
konu anlatımı ncom siteme
gidebilirsiniz kendi ilinizde bir özel
ders öğretmeni arıyorsanız da özel
ders.com sitesine bakabilirsiniz şimdi
film alıntılarım gelsin
[Müzik]
Doctor has to Report it to the
police you got to have Someone to take
Advantage
of um i'll need to see some id Of course
He Said He had to talk
to i didn't need
to i did What i had to do All you Got To
Do is Get the money
Jesus Christ por you need to see A
Doctor
yeah then i Guess You must be the Lucky
girl Well i Got to get
Going Thanks i have to go and see
Another
Guy i had to see Just to make Sure i
wasn't in
hell We must have some pretty wonderful
Friends
Johnny My dad Never bought Me A Ferrari
i had to Steal My First One
şimdi öğrendiğimiz Bu konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz bunun için çeviri
ile öğreni kullanacağız sizden Türkçe
cümleleri İngilizceye çevirmeniz
isteyeceğim Biraz sonra cümleleri
ekranda gördüğünüz zaman videoyu
durdurun ve kendinize 5 dakika kadar
süre tanıyın Hazırsanız
başlayalım
f f
[Müzik]
two İngilizce öğrenmeli miyim cümlesinde
melim malı yapısı bana Mask ve şuttan
bir tanesini kullanmam gerektiğini
hatırlatıyor bu cümlede sanki tavsiye
isteyen birisinin sorusu gibi geldi bana
bu yüzden should kullanmak daha doğru
olacak should i Learn English Ayrıca
zaten soru cümlesinde mas kullanımının
pek tercih edilmediğini de söylemiştim
hasta görünüyorsun dinlenmelisin
yine bir melim malı ifadesi geçiyor ve
burada bir tavsiye olduğunu görüyorum
yine şut kullanmam uygun olacaktır
y Arabanızı engelli alanına Park
etmemelisiniz Bu bir tavsiyede sertlik
derecesi biraz daha fazla olan bir yasak
bir kural gibi geldi bana Dolayısıyla
burada mustn't kullanmak daha uygun
olacak
Par e kulesini Mutlaka ziyaret etmelisin
bu cümlede bir tavsiye var ama çok güçlü
bir tavsiye yapılıyor mutlaka kelimesi
de kullanılmış must böyle bir özelliği
olduğunu
söylemiştim O buradan ayrılmak zorunda
mıydı zorunda olmak ifadesi geçiyor bu
bana to kullanmam gerektiğini hatırlattı
ancak cümlenin de di geçmiş zamandı
olduğuna dikkat edelim o yüzden simple
past tense kuralları gereğince yapacağız
cümleyi hoşunuza gittiyse devamını
çeviriyle öğren kitabımda bulabilirsiniz
tanıtım ve Sati sayfasına gitmek için
sağ üst köşedeki i harfine
tıklayabilirsiniz Ayrıca bu kanala
ekleyeceğim yeni videolardan haberdar
olmak için sol üst köşeye tıklayarak
kanalıma abone olabilirsiniz izlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim Bir sonraki videoda
görüşmek üzere hoşça kalın
[Müzik]
h